to what degree do you think
I do agree with this notion that both
sides are the same it's a popular way
to acknowledge that your side has done
something wrong
but while framing it as it's not
uniquely wrong and it's not worse than
what anybody else does and I find that
it's one of the lamest and most kind of
cringe-inducing things to hear because
of the what comes next and usually what
comes next is not
a good accurate criticism of something
that took place and a discussion of how
to solve a real problem that we have I
find that a conversation Stifler it also
is used to kind of suppress voter
turnout not actively it's not that the
people who say that go around saying
don't vote but the idea of course is the
more people that believe that it doesn't
really make a difference who you vote
for it's going to suppress voter turnout
and I want voter turnout to be as high
as possible not as low as possible so I
also dislike it for that reason